et was the first stop for the stars
talking about the final saga as a Star
Wars franchise
that's right Rachel this is the place to
be celebrating 40 years of Star Wars at
the premiere of the rise of Skywalker
you some you're like oh my god it's the
last one
are we okay I mean what fine babe hey
babe we are five years going strong love
Harrison Ford Mark Hamill the property
brothers Jonathan Scott brought
girlfriend Zooey Deschanel they were all
among the galaxy of stars who shut down
Hollywood Boulevard last night just like
they did when the first film in this
trilogy premiered
we were standing in this very spot I was
terrified I was shaking as I am now
shivering and sweaty that really
attractive combination what was going
through my head was I'm so scared but
there's the beginning to something
really cool going through your head in
this moment no I was so drunk I said I
don't know who I'm hugging but it feels
good star wars the rise of Skywalker
brings the intergalactic saga to a close
watching the movie was bittersweet for
Daisy
he's Daisy Ridley what was the face you
made when the credits
[Music]
I know whenever I'm running here and
you're ruining it lingo and then I had
to watch some friends to wind down by
the way this movie which is the last one
in the skywalker saga is expected to
rake in as much as two hundred million
dollars on opening week alone
[Music]